de que deben ser controlados,
que tienen que salir de las identidades de su hogar
para tener éxito.
Todos los niños merecen una educación
que garantice la seguridad de aprender
con la comodidad de su propia piel.
(Aplausos)
Es posible crear emocional y físicamente aulas seguras
donde los estudiantes también prosperen académicamente.
Lo sé, porque lo hice en mi aula
cuando volví a enseñar en el Bronx.
Entonces, ¿qué se ve?
Centré mi instrucción
en las vidas, historias e identidades de mis alumnos.
E hice todo esto porque quería que mis estudiantes supieran
que todo el mundo alrededor de ellos estaba apoyándolos
para ser lo mejor de sí mismos.
Así que aunque no podía controlar la inestabilidad de sus hogares,
la incertidumbre de su próxima comida,
o los vecinos ruidosos que los mantenían en vela,
yo les proporcionaba un aula cariñosa
que les hacía sentir orgullosos de ser quienes eran,
que hizo saber que ellos importaban.
Ya saben,
cada vez que escucho o digo la palabra "asking" -preguntando-
vuelvo a la secundaria de nuevo.
Estoy pensando en "ass" -culo- y en "king" -rey-
y lo pongo junto para hablar de una manera
donde alguien en el poder va a querer escuchar.
Hay una mejor manera,
que no obliga a estar a los niños de color en un dilema;
una manera en que pueden preservar los lazos
con sus familias, hogares y comunidades;
una manera que les enseña a confiar en sus instintos
y tener fe en su propio genio creativo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)